la direction de trappes à présent le
centre emmaüs ce qui est située dans la
ville de trappes doit se trouver de
nouveaux locaux il cite lui 201 avenue
des bouleaux emmaüs trap est en fin de
bail sur le bâtiment il n'est plus
possible de venir faire des dépôts de
prendre rendez vous pour un ramassage
malgré la fermeture le 30 juin
l'association restera mon activité en
louant des bureaux pour rechercher un
nouveau site est dédié à la vente
aucun dépôt ne sera possible durant
cette période on écoute le responsable
du site me donner plus de détails sur
cette fermeture c'est un bail précaire
qui avait été mis en place au mois de
janvier 2015
dans l'objectif de d'acheter le bâtiment
à l'issue du bail précaire et puis pour
un certain nombre de raisons notamment
financières cet achat n'a pas pu se
faire
on a prolongé le bail précaire de
décembre 2015 jusqu'à rejoint 2016 et
puis maintenant le propriétaire ne veut
pas le prolonger donc on fait une petite
pause en espérant redémarrer fin 2016
dans un domaine dans un établissement
qui sera tout à fait adapté l'activité